All right, so I've got an interesting collection of names here.
I had to include Michael because it is a relevant name to me,
but in fact, in 1995, it was the most popular name given in the US,
more popular than any of the names given to any of the women and in fact,
Matthew is the second highest male name,
but I didn't ask for male names, I asked for female names.
The most popular female name given was Jessica,
and I think that was actually most popular for a good solid decade or two.
That's been very popular for a very long time
as had Michael been in decades and decades and decades.
This is no longer the most popular given name, but it was for a long time.
The second most popular female name is Ashley.
Well, Zuzana was among the least popular, and Taylor was pretty popular
and pretty distinctive to that year but not the second most popular in that year.